For millennia, humans
have turned to plants
to heal the sick and wounded,
to ward against evil
and grant magical powers.
But what happens when plants
themselves become conscious
and turn killers?
More monstrous associations
link vegetation
to malevolent sorcery,
demonic influence,
or evil and, typically,
human-like qualities.
Characteristics like
extremely large size,
enhanced mobility,
including sentient movement,
an insatiable carnivorous diet,
and poisonous excretions
can all make a harmless plant
into a terrifying monster.
The most common unifying element
of terror among these
so-called monstrous plants?
Their ability and
desire to kill humans.
[energetic music]
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka
and this is Monstrum.
Poisonous plants like hemlock
and belladonna are lethal
to humans and have
been employed as such.
Given these potentially
devastating consequences,
some of this vegetation
was associated
with mystical properties,
especially if they also
possessed an unusual appearance.
Orchids were associated with
witchcraft, deadly nightshade
and mandrakes with Satan.
These real-world deadly plants
helped inspire the folklore
around their monstrous cousins,
the ones that kill
consciously on their own.
One early example appears
in the medieval period
in a natural history
encyclopedia.
Published in 1491,
Meydenbach's Ortus Sanitatis
includes a description
and illustration
of the bausor tree.
It was said to exude toxic
fumes that caused death
for miles around for any
living thing, even humans.
Some 250 years later in
1783, an article appeared
in "The London Magazine" by
Dutch surgeon, N.P. Foersch,
who told of the existence
of a strange tree,
the Javanese Upas.
He alleged that on
the island of Java,
there existed a tree
whose biology was
so sensational, it had
previously been dismissed
as myth by European naturalists.
According to Foersch,
indigenous peoples called
this plant the Bohun Upas.
With the permission of the
government and the help
of two Malayan priests,
Foersch claims that he was able
to observe the tree himself,
from a distance, of course,
as not only the bark of the tree
but the fumes emanating
from its resin are
lethal to all life.
The only humans
who approach the tree
are condemned criminals
given a chance at clemency
if they can successfully harvest
the poisonous secretions.
The existence of Foersch
and his record
of the tree are still contested.
Historical documents show
that a surgeon named
John Nichols Foersch
did indeed exist,
and that the man lived
in the East Indies.
This surgeon expressed interest
in writing a book
about his travels.
So it is possible he
concocted the Bohun Upas story
as a publicity stunt.
However,
other historians attribute
"The London Magazine" article
to an anonymous source who
spun the tale from scratch.
Either way, there is a real tree
with poisonous sap we now
call the Antiaris toxicaria,
that was undoubtedly
well-known among inhabitants
of its natural habitats.
But it wasn't until
sensationalized accounts
like this one
in the 18th century
that this deadly plant
was turned
into a plant that killed.
Many such stories weren't
just tabloid fodder,
but were nonetheless
just as sensational.
Naturalist Erasmus Darwin
wrote of the Javanese Upas tree
and its poisonous vapor
in his 1789 text,
The Botanic Garden,
offering the compelling image
of a barren land
surrounding the plant,
punctuated only by the
skeletons of men and animals.
While not the man-eating plant
trope we've come to recognize
as characteristic
of killer flora,
these early literary appearances
planted imaginative seeds
that would flourish
in the 19th century.
As the steam engine advanced
and expediated trade routes,
transport of plants from
one side of the globe
to the other became more
successful in the 19th century.
Improvements in glass
and steel production used
to build greenhouses
and the invention
of the hothouse made cultivation
of foreign
plant species possible
in previously unfit climates.
Alongside this
perennial privilege,
plants as intruders was an
increasingly dominant narrative
in the 1800s.
Wild and unkempt at best
or sentient and mobile
in the most
horrifying variations,
the idea of encroaching
vegetation appeared
across literary genres.
Fictional travel accounts
increasingly featured exotic
killer plants; Gothic tales
and short stories of weird
vegetation became popular,
meaning an influx
in the perception
that flora could
consume animal flesh,
including the occasional human.
This is in part due
to a scientific text
and another Darwin.
Charles Darwin's 1875 book,
Insectivorous Plants,
popularized the
flesh-eating plant.
The vibrantly illustrated text
details the
naturalist's experiments
with carnivorous plants,
their movements,
digestive processes,
and favorite food sources.
Nature, it became apparent,
supported natural monsters,
and inevitably,
fiction writers would expand
upon their existence
in dramatic ways.
Fake accounts of
man-eating plants emerged
in publications around
that same decade.
Perhaps the most
widely popularized
of these tales was "The
Man-Eating Tree of Madagascar."
On April 28th, 1874,
The New York World published
an incredible story
detailing the account of
Karl Leche's discovery
of a tentacled carnivorous
man-eating pitcher plant
in Madagascar.
He claimed the tree was
worshiped by locals,
secreted a hallucinogenic sap,
and used vine-like
tentacles to trap its victim
while pointed leaves
squashed them to death.
More than ten years later,
in 1888,
the story was
revealed as a hoax.
But by that time,
fiction writers were filling
in the gaps of imaginations,
turning newspaper stories
into sensational
horror narratives.
Take Arthur Conan Doyle's
The Americans' Tale,
a short story about a giant
carnivorous Venus flytrap
in Montana;
or Phil Robinson's
The Man-Eating Tree,
where an African
man-sucking tree
with beautiful golden fruit
serves as a lure
to grab nearby prey
with its boughs before using
large vampire-like leaves
to suck the blood
of its victims.
In Lucy H. Hooper's
1889 Carnivorine,
the mad scientist trope
enters into the genre
with a botanist who attempts
to prove an
evolutionary connection
between plant and animal.
As a result of his experiments,
the plant develops
paddle-like feet,
making it mobile, and a taste
for human flesh,
resulting in an
uncontrollable killer monster.
And in 1891,
the horrible plant called the
Devil's Snare was introduced
by an American naturalist
living in Nicaragua.
Like a weeping willow
without foliage,
the thick dark black vines
appear like a mass
of interlacing
thick muscular fibers.
Vines that suck blood,
of course.
In 1894, H.G. Wells'
The Flowering
of the Strange Orchid
tells the tale
of a British orchid collector
whose newest procurement
from the Indies, whose buds
resemble little white fingers,
ends up nearly strangling him
using sucker-adorned roots
to drink his blood.
Noticing a trend here?
The plants in these narratives
come from outside of Europe.
Many killer plant stories
from the 19th century
and beyond represent
the unconquered
and uncontrollable
natural world.
Colonialism plays a role here
as writers turned
passively poisonous flora
into predatory
man-eating beasts,
painting the foreign as
dangerous and terrifying
as a means to affirm
Western superiority.
At the turn of the 20th century,
plants were
increasingly considered
with curiosity,
suspicion, and fear
in both scientific texts
and horror fiction.
The 1920s and '30s saw a swell
in monstrous plant narratives.
Pulp science fiction was
thriving at the time,
but so were debates about
teaching evolutionary theory
in schools, ones that
made national headlines
with The Scopes Trial.
Fostered by the
uncertainty of the Cold War
and the rapidly evolving
scientific discoveries
of the '50s and '60s,
monster plants
popped up regularly
on screen and in books.
Speculation surrounding
the potential impacts
of nuclear mutation,
extraterrestrial life,
bio-weapons, and chemical
herbicides present themselves
in monstrous plant narratives.
In the famous
The Day of the Triffids,
a postapocalyptic 1951 novel
by John Wyndham,
mysterious plants are a metaphor
for fears of the Cold War.
When a comet blinds most
of the world's population,
humankind becomes vulnerable
to walking stinging plants
first bred
by the Soviet Union during
genetic experimentation
and accidentally
released into the world.
The triffid plants
evolve to prey on humans,
using the global catastrophe
to dominate the planet.
That same year, in the film
The Thing from Another World,
killer extraterrestrial plants
wreak havoc on Earth.
Inspired in part by growing
reports of UFOs and aliens,
as well as rumored accounts of
Soviet forces in the Arctic,
the film's plant-based
alien life form is defrosted
by military personnel and
scientists in the North Pole.
If this plot sounds familiar,
that's because it is.
Both this movie and
1982's The Thing were based
on a 1938 novel
by John W. Campbell, Jr.
In 1956, Invasion of
the Body Snatchers
would make monstrous
plants more terrifying
by giving them the
ability to clone humans.
Then The Woman Eater paid homage
to the 19th century sensational
man-killer plant narratives
with a carnivorous tree
worshiped by locals.
And 1960 brought us the hapless
Skid Row florist Seymour,
who cultivates a blood-thirsty
potted plant,
hoping to use the novelty to
advance his own standing
with his boss and propagate
his own love life.
In the original 1960s
version of the film,
Audrey, Jr, defeats
and eats Seymour.
Audiences of the 1986 version
of Little Shop watch
a more pleasant
and reassuring ending,
when it is instead Seymour
who defeats Audrey, Jr.
Audrey, Jr. immortalizes
its victim's faces
in its blooming flowers,
which the historian in me
can't help but interpret
as a callback
to the Wak Wak tree.
First recorded in the late
14th century Book of Surprises,
the bizarre tree appears in
multiple Indo Arabian legends,
where it is said to
grow either human heads
or full-bodied humans
amongst its branches.
In the 1970s and '80s,
advances in bioengineering led
to a flurry of dangerous
flora narratives
in response to anxieties
about the consequences
of bioengineering.
Venus Flytrap returns
to the premise
Hooper first introduced
in the 19th century,
when a botanist looking to
prove human life evolved
from plants accidentally
creates a monster.
In 1985, "Super Mario"'s
piranha plants, inspired in part
by the real-life invasive plant
species Hydnora africana,
immortalized killer plants
in video games.
And in 1989,
the plant-based Kaiju,
Biollante, joined the
Godzilla franchise.
Since the 21st century,
killer plants in horror
and science fiction narratives
have become more varied
in appearance, origin,
and definition.
From the more obvious
interpretations,
creeping carnivorous vines
and anthropomorphic
tree stump babies
to unseen parasitic fungi that
cause humans to crave flesh
and psychedelic alien spores,
we still have the tendency
to transform nature into
something frightening.
The biological systems of plants
are dramatically different
from other life forms.
Most make their own food
and breathe what
we exhale as waste.
It is more challenging
for us to draw similarities
between flora than fauna.
Even when we try to
make comparisons,
like with the mandrake,
large duck orchid,
or bleeding heart flowers,
the analogy is
never fully formed.
This extreme otherness
can heighten the terror
when they turn monstrous,
exploiting our discomfort
with living beings
whose very existence is
so dramatically
different from our own.
So next time you gaze lovingly
at the plant sitting serenely
in the corners of your home,
spilling leaves
over bookcase shelves
and silently swinging
from macrame hammocks,
remember that it is
in the quietness,
that seeming meekness,
that the killer plant
lies ready to strike.
So have you talked
to your plants today?
If you love the outdoors,
we think you'll really enjoy
the newest digital
series from PBS
called "America
Outdoors: Understory."
Hosted by Baratunde Thurston,
the show explores
our passionate,
yet complex relationship
with the natural world.
Along the way, you
get to meet everyone
from surfing scientists
to fossil hunters.
There's a link in
the description.
We hope you go check it out,
and then maybe go
get some fresh air.
(Speaker)
Rolling.
What is that?
Upas.
(Speaker)
This one's native.
Ooh.
Plant.
I really want a Venus
flytrap as a pet.
Hey.
(Speaker)
It's like an alien spaceship.
Nyu nyu nyu.
Accessibility provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.